[Music]
if the holy being was postulated in
order that in it duty might have its
validity not as pure duty but as a
multiplicity of specific duties then
this again must be dissembled and the
other being alone must be holy insofar
as only pure Duty has validity in it
pure Duty has also in point of fact
validity only at another being not in
the moral consciousness although in the
latter it seems that pure morality alone
has validity the position must be put in
another way for it is at the same time a
natural consciousness in it morality is
affected and conditioned by the sense
nature and is therefore not free and
independent but contingent on freewill
in it however as pure will morality is
contingent on knowledge morality
therefore in and for itself is in
another being
we're now nearing the end of this
section decembe lens or duplicity fish
Talon in German and here in paragraph
627 Hegel is once again having the moral
consciousness as it's sort of blundering
through its attempts to try to live up
to that to be genuinely moral articulate
itself once again in relation to this
holy being is hiding is Vaes and you
could also say holy essence if you want
and you wouldn't be off track there
because in a way it really is the
essence in the sense of being the
universal or what's supposed to be there
in the moral consciousness and he begins
this passage by talking about again
specific duties and pure duty and
specific meaning not just particular but
duties that we actually have in relation
to real people in real situations or
perhaps even imagined situations but
they are conditioned by some sorts of
limitations they don't apply to every
single case although they could be quite
general they're not the same thing as
pure Duty itself but what is pure Duty
itself we saw other people struggling to
articulate that even Kant himself
provides us with something that's rather
formal and abstract and and you might
even say in some respect hostile to or
dismissive of the real reality the the
actuality the moral consciousness in its
world that we live within so Hegel says
if the holy being was postulated in
order that in it Duty might have its
validity its galtung right it might be
worth something it might be valid in
some way
not as pure duty but as a multiplicity
of specific duties the kind of duties
that we actually do have as human beings
this then again must be dissembled this
must be fair stealth all right it must
be and I think about what this fish
Talon means you've got the the Stalin
the setting fourth right the structuring
and instead of four which would be
representation or representing right
it's one thing representing another fear
Stalin you're you're you're setting it
out wrongly you're deforming it in some
way you're introducing what later on
somebody might call ideology right so he
goes on and he says this must be
dissembled and the other being alone
must be holy all insofar as only pure
duty has validity in it the other being
being this holy being and this is in a
beyond right one of the peculiarities of
human existence is that we don't just
stay with our actuality we can think
beyond it and we can even feel beyond it
right we can place ourselves beyond the
reality the phenomenal world that we are
encountering the benefit that we
actually pay attention to it and
register we can we can find something
like this that strictly speaking doesn't
exist but can matter more than the
things that actually do exist and then
the question is well what sort of
relationship do we have with that how do
we conceive of ourselves in relation to
it so he goes on and says pure duty has
in point of fact validity only in
another being only in this holy being
not in the moral consciousness of the
actually existing person so he says
although in the latter it seems that
pure morality alone has validity the
position must be put in another way if
the moral consciousness is going to be
moral it has to be by recognizing pure
duty but it can't
pure duty within it so to speak as
constitutive of its entire structure of
motivation why not because as Hegel is
going to say it is affected its morality
is affected and conditioned dinked right
by the sense nature by sensibilities in
leak-tight the the entire range of what
we call the the sense nature sensibility
our lower level of engagement with the
world and indeed engagement with our own
selves insofar as we are bodies and you
know we can think of ourselves in that
way we'll put that aside for the moment
and so what does he mean by this
Sensibility well you think back again to
Kant and because in Cantus takes on a
particular starkness well it's not as if
can't originates this idea completely
there's plenty of people before him that
are contrasting sensibility against you
know rationality you can see that going
all the way back to its a Plato with the
appetites versus reason but in cons we
get that this sensibility this
sensuousness part of our nature
the phenomenal part of what it is to be
a human being is always conditioned by
its desire for happiness by our desires
inclinations instincts however you want
to put this we have some sort of
orientation some sort of drive and that
keeps us as we've seen in these previous
paragraphs from being purely moral from
being entirely Duty driven Duty
recognizing even we have a almost
infinite capacity for self-deception
telling ourselves that by following
self-love or some inclination we're
actually doing the right thing so he
says in the moral consciousness morality
is is going to be conditioned by the
sense nature
and is therefore not free and
independent not free and independent
what is free free will we're going to
come back to that in a moment they says
in it meaning the holy being as pure
will pure will meaning the will that is
in fact pure morality is contingent on
knowledge on this so he says morality
therefore in and for itself is in
another being the moral consciousness
doesn't really have morality in and for
itself
it's rather in this other holy being
that's a problem now let's come back and
talk a little bit about this distinction
that's being made here between a pure
will and a free will and how this
affects things in the next paragraph the
pure will is going to get discussed a
little bit more so we'll come back to
that but this is an interesting thought
to think isn't it morality is being made
contingent upon free will what does that
mean now one way of reading this would
be to say well you know unless you
actually have freedom to choose we can't
really hold you responsible you know we
get the old freedom and determinism and
whether you can be punished or rewarded
discussion or praised or blamed right
that's true that's important but that's
not what Hegel is actually talking about
here so what is he on about in
discussing this it's up to us because we
do have free will as moral consciousness
to decide whether we want to do the
right thing or not whether we want to
incline ourselves towards what our
desires bid us to do or whether we
choose instead to use that free will
which is free precisely because it can
turn itself as long as Dean as an some
and so many other theorists of the will
before us and even those who didn't call
it will like Epictetus or even Aristotle
with pro racists recognized we have this
capacity to turn ourselves towards one
thing or another we could turn ourselves
towards morality we could turn our
towards recognizing what pure duty
requires of us but we don't have to as a
matter of fact much of the time we don't
ask on points out all right and so
there's a double contingency introduced
here at Zoo Fellig kite right they could
work out or it could not work out on
this side we have freewill on this side
we have knowledge in both senses
morality has made something contingent
and that's a problem
this other being then is here the purely
perfect morality for in it morality does
not stand in a relation to nature and
sense but the reality of pure Duty is
its realization in nature and sense the
moral consciousness attributes its
imperfection to the fact that in it
morality has a positive relation to
nature and sense because it holds that
an essential moment in morality is that
it should have a negative and only a
negative relation to them the pure moral
being on the other hand because it is
above the struggle with nature and sense
does not stand in a negative relation to
them therefore in fact their remains for
it only the positive relation to them
that is just what a moment ago was qua
imperfect held to be amoral but a pure
morality that was completely separated
from reality and so likewise was without
any positive relation to it would be an
unconscious unreal abstraction in which
the concept of morality which involves
thinking of pure duty willing and doing
it would be done away with such a purely
moral being is therefore again ad
assemblance of the facts and has to be
given up
in paragraph 628 again we're gonna see
counterpoise to each other these two
same sides but now the initiative is
going to shift back over to the side of
the imperfect moral consciousness the
actually existing human being who is
recognizing and attempting to be moral
by fulfilling some duties at least and
who recognizes the failure on their part
that they have greater duties indeed a
purer duty that they ought to be living
up to and so Hegel begins this by saying
this other being what is the other being
the holy will if you want to use a
contrary information formulation we
could call it the perfect morality
epitomised or embodied if that
metaphorical language wasn't a little
bit misleading we could just say it is
the abstracted Hegel is going to use
this term abstract this abstracted pure
morality that has been given a kind of
agency but now it's going to show us
that that notion of agency is actually
off base here agency in its real sense
lies on the side of the imperfect moral
consciousness so Hegel begins by saying
that this other being is here the purely
perfect morality notice pure and perfect
it's brought about to its fulfillment it
is pure it has been purified of any sort
of admixture or determination or
conditioning by Sensibility by reality
or actuality of human beings and you
could say well what what is that then
well it may in fact be a bit of an
abstraction or to you know jump ahead to
somebody else with drew and Hegel may be
something of a a spook right a spirit
that isn't really Geist in its full
sense but sort of something that we
construct and project out there you
different Feuerbach or sterner plenty of
others as well that's a real danger in
talking about pure morality isn't it
that it we lose sight if we don't think
it through all the way we lose sight of
what it is that is telling us what to do
isn't really fit to tell us what to do
because it doesn't have the actuality
that we are ascribing to it it doesn't
have to use the previous paragraphs
formulation it doesn't have the validity
the golden kite that we want it to have
so he goes on and he says the reality of
pure duty is its realization it's being
made veer click it's it's being made
actual in in nature and in sense what do
we mean by this in this world that we
actually do live in and about which we
can make at least generalizations if not
laws not only about natural processes
physical processes biological processes
but even psychological and sociological
generalizations as well things like
people tend to like people who give them
nice things you know now those sorts of
generalizations that do admit of many
other possibilities as Aristotle points
out but which we can trust for the most
part and why can we trust it for the
most part because the natural world
insofar as it has to do with wills those
wills are largely conditioned by desires
inclinations habits and in that sense
they're less than free and in that sense
it when they do the right thing if you
they do the right thing for example
because they've been educated and
conditioned from birth to do the right
thing they're not really doing the right
thing in a full sense they're not
fulfilling strict duty
what about sense the world of sense
Sensibility we just talked about that in
the previous paragraph right again we
have this world in which we are drawn to
objects in which we feel desires and
inclinations motivating us so we can go
on from that
and he says the reality of peer duties
it's realization in this in nature and
in sense in this world that we live in
and this is something worth dwelling on
a little bit there's a continual
movement in Hegel's thought that runs
throughout the entire phenomenology and
indeed his philosophy in general it's
it's sometimes articulated in saying
that the rational is real and the real
is rational and people take that as an
endpoint when really it's describing
what ought to be the case the rational
whatever it is that we're thinking
whatever highest thing that we're
grappling with then we orient ourselves
towards and say wow I want some of that
I'm gonna change myself to fit this I'm
gonna change my thinking my feeling my
acting my willing my relations to others
so that I can be part of this that has
to be made real it has to be made actual
likewise the actual just by itself is
kind of stupid and meaningless and
requires being made rational not
rational in a sense where it's being
deprived of everything that that makes
it interesting rational in a full sense
which would take the world in front of
us and show us deeper aspects to it
that's what's ablation out Haven is
really about and that's driving the
whole process and here it's happening
with morality all right back now from
the heights of sort of generalizing
about Hegel back to this this section so
Hegel says that the moral consciousness
attributes its imperfection at this
stage right it's attributing its
imperfection to the fact that in it
morality or pure Duty has its it has a
positive relation to nature and sense
what does that mean that it has a
positive relation to nature and sense in
a living human being in a real person
whatever is going to be occurring or
even driving a person
terms of morality or pure duty is going
to happen because of the choice of that
person we just talked about this in last
paragraph their free will
conditions or makes contingent morality
right and it does so in a in a realm of
nature or sense we can think of our
drives our inclinations our experiences
all of that impinges upon morality it
has a positive relation to it not
positive in the sense of positive value
but positive in the sense that it's it's
saying you can fit into this framework
we're going to connect up together but
then that means that the morality is
actually imperfect it's not really fully
brought about on the other hand for the
moral consciousness he says the moral
consciousness holds that an essential
moment in morality we've seen this from
the very start is that it should have a
negative and only negative relationship
to them to nature and sense it should be
saying no no don't follow your
inclinations no don't follow self-love
no don't worry about the esteem of other
people no it's giving a no over and over
and over again and then it's saying yes
to something purely formal something
generalizable beyond the general to the
universal right and that's this negative
relation it's it's imposing a no on
nature and sense and saying if you mix
it up with that you're screwing it up
completely what about the other side so
Hegel then says the pure moral being
because it's above the struggle with
nature and sense now why is he talking
about struggle their struggle is exactly
what the moral consciousness experiences
this is why it has to determine its own
free will am I going to do what duty
bids me to do or am I going to do what
feels good if we want to use just one
formulation or what's gonna pay off for
me
I can't ant both I can tell myself I can
have both but I'm lying to myself that
my will have
to choose and it has to choose in
struggle so the perfect will doesn't
struggle like that it has what seems to
be a purely negative relationship to
nature and sense but it has a purely
positive relationship with morality
right says it doesn't stand in a
negative relation to them to nature and
sense because it doesn't struggle
against them there's only a positive
relation and what was qua imperfect held
to be amoral so insofar as it emerges
into the world you have to do a sort of
thought experiment here the holy will
intrudes itself into our screwed-up
phenomenal existence where we all have
these contradictory motives and we're
kind of a mess and this one is perfect
it comes in you might you know have the
heavens open up and that uh angels
singing kind of sound however you want
to imagine it right it could just be
some some guy on the street who happens
to be morally perfect
hey like that son what if God was one of
us right that was so popular years back
and that's what we're talking about here
we're talking about pure morality
embodying itself now within the world
and it can't do wrong they can't do
anything bad
you know it's interesting because the
Incarnation this is a bit of a side note
made Christian authors have to think
about this quite a bit you've got this
Jesus character showing up who Christian
theologians and philosophers are saying
is not just the Son of God but God
incarnate and the question is could God
first let's start a general question
could God take away any sort of bodily
existence do anything that was ever
wrong could God lie to you for example
or could God you know tell you that
wrong is right and and the standard
Orthodox approach of this is no because
then God wouldn't be God right there's
something about the divine nature that
doesn't do that but now mix up
Adie into it take what Kierkegaard is
later gonna call the intrusion or the
breaking in of the eternal into time
right through this this person could
that person do the wrong thing could
that person even be tempted to do the
wrong thing this is a live question that
Hegel is going to talk a little bit more
about once we get to the religion
section and definitely in his lectures
on the philosophy of religion and it's
worth thinking about here or now to come
back to the Hagel tax must we conceive
of the intrusion of the holy will into
the world as something like a a
programmed algorithm or a robot that
cannot do otherwise precisely because of
its own goodness now notice what Hegel
says here he says there remains only the
positive relation right a pure morality
that was as he says completely separated
from reality and so likewise was without
any positive relation to it notice the
terms he's gonna use here would be an
unconscious one bolused
right not knowing remembered knowledge
in the previous paragraph was what
morality was being made contingent on
this right so unbel
in which the concept of morality now
notice what Hegel is gonna say here the
concept of morality the be gracious the
very actuality the living spirit of
morality what does it involve it
involves the human being thinking it
involves the human being willing it
involves the human being acting and then
repeat the cycle over and over and over
again every single one of those is
integral to what it means to be a moral
agent you cannot be a moral agent if you
don't have to think about it if it's
totally set out in front of you and it's
perfectly clear and you just follow
along with that you cannot be a moral
agent without also willing which
involves some sort of freedom you cannot
be a moral agent without acting and you
must act within an actuality and with a
being that is shot through with
worldliness and with what Hegel here is
going to call nature and sense so what
do we find he says such a purely moral
being what we've been projecting here is
again ad assemblance of the facts and
has to be given up how are we going to
give it up that's the question ahead of
us
in this purely moral being however the
moments of the contradiction in which
this synthetic presentation of them
flounders about are brought closer
together and consciousness lets these
opposites follow one after the other one
always being replaced by the other
without bringing its thoughts together
so that in the end it is forced to give
up its moral view of the world and seek
refuge within itself
here in this short paragraph 629 Hegel
is engaging in a bit of summing up and
also leading us to something not
entirely new but at least an alternative
to these and we're getting very close to
the end of this section there's only two
more paragraphs after this and they're
gonna really be working out and leading
into the next final section of morality
on the basis of what's happening or
what's realized here in this paragraph
so Hegel tells us that in this purely
moral being which he's now revealed to
us to be an abstraction unreal
unconscious moral consciousness is not
able to find its home he says instead
the moments of the contradiction which
is in German vitas book right we have an
actual contradiction going on here but
it's not a contradiction that's
productive in the sense of you know
thesis antithesis synthesis the one
contradicts the other leads to the to
the final synthesis of all these other
things you can use this term you know
synthetic here instead what we have is
you might say an escape route
consciousness realizes that it can't do
what it wanted to do with these
determinations with what he's going to
call the moments of this contradiction
so he says in this purely moral being
the moments of this contradiction in
which this synthetic presentation of
them flounders about we're going to come
back to that they're brought closer
together and consciousness in bringing
them closer together now enters into
this you might say indeterminable
period of going back and forth until
finally it's going to say I can't do
anything with this but it has to go
through that labor of trying to bring
them you might say like almost like
bending a steel bar to
bring it closer and closer but it's it's
actually a steel bar that has magnets
let's pretend that they're magnets with
opposed ends and think it's tougher to
tougher to bring them together they're
the same end rather you know the
positive repel repelling the positive
and it goes back and forth and you go
from one to the other that's what's
happening here and notice that what
we've got in this entire section is a
Farish dialogue right dissemblers and
this purely moral being is itself a
dissemble ins on the part of the moral
consciousness and we have a force tellin
right we have a representation also
carried out by the moral consciousness
so there's a lot of work that the moral
consciousness is doing here without
realizing it without taking stock of it
instead it thinks that it's exploring
these ideas which are really its own
ideas and not realities out there
somewhere that it is contemplating and
so he says consciousness lets these
opposites these opposed moments and what
does he mean they're all these opposed
moments in these dialectics that we have
traversed through this section and the
previous section of morality where you
know we're say opposing happiness to
morality or nature to morality or the
moral consciousness to pure duty
whatever it happens to be we're not able
to bring these ideas together and hold
them in some sort of synthetic unity
instead we have a synthetic presentation
which doesn't do justice to them we are
able to present them we are able to
represent them but it doesn't fully make
sense it's not yet at the level of the
concept the notion that be good if so he
says these follow one after the other
one always being replaced by the other
without bringing its thoughts together
what is the end result of this so in the
end it's forced to give up its moral
view of the world and to seek refuge in
itself so the moral view of the world
which we began with not only at the
beginning of this section but the
previous section the entire morality
section the moral view of the world has
been abandoned and now it takes refuge
in itself does this mean that it's going
to give up on morality altogether no the
answer is pretty clear about that but
then how is it going to find within
itself what it couldn't find in all of
these dialectical investigations of
morality and the moral view of the world
and the moral consciousness well that's
what we have to see coming up in the
next few paragraphs and in the final
section of this morality portion of the
work
you